[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  I can't wait forever I'm not that  patient I've got too many things to -  you're comfy like a sweater but when the  Sun comes out I won't be needing you  you smile turn  the secret and it's a sickly sweet that  I can't see the point of taking deeper  and through a selfish life it's just so  beautiful  I don't  while your song  please don't make this to go cold  your rides making me feel dizzy when you  quiz me on my childhood hit movie I'll  share with you if you so kindly cut me  hole so I can  [Music]  I threw the crack so protocol  you straight army but instead I enjoy  this view that I saw shallowly  [Music]  please  Oh  waiting for what you did sir cream but  you only see from them right here's  where we both are and too afraid to turn  we have fun  I  [Music]  [Music]  I won't be easy  [Music]  your genes are in shock you just like  put your thumb in the box yeah all right  [Applause]